[Music]
[Laughter]
hey everybody
[Laughter]
happy new years eve
daley got with this mexican batman
mexican babe
mexican bait yeah what how do you say
batman in spanish
batman essay
[Laughter]
last time i saw you i broke your bones
next time i see you i'm going to break
your soul
that's 10 that's danny trejo [ __ ]
bane
well there you go yeah i'm sure there's
a version of that out there so there he
is yeah he did he did some voice acting
for him yeah i thought he did i thought
he might have that's pretty funny gram
there's hammer says whoa nacho libre
yeah
this is a genuine
uh mexican luchadori mask from mexico
batman well duh
yeah what's that batman well yeah
that's what that's what you are
we're yeah we're uh we kind of like
dress up a little bit because we're
gonna go to mannequins afterward
hopefully we don't regret this we don't
usually go out new year's eve but
our friends are going out we haven't
seen them in a while it's a fetish party
yeah i forgot about that even though i
did the poster but it was a long time
ago but then like yesterday i'm like oh
[ __ ] it's like a whole fetish ball isn't
i don't feel like dressing up for that
i'm not and i got my band craft you know
yeah murder horde instead says tom can't
drink with that on no i gotta take it
off yeah he's gonna have to take the
mask off
we'll see now now you know what us girls
have to put up with with all of this
like complicated [ __ ] well it's like
you can't eat with this lipstick on and
i can't do this with all this hair on
and i can't go to the bathroom with a
corset on and i can't do this that the
other thing
it's just kind of like i just have to
stand there and look cool yeah
i got a damn drink here so i got i got
to [ __ ] take the mask off
yeah tila says i'm staying my ass in
tonight we usually do
but
we haven't actually we haven't been to
mannequins in a while and i felt kind of
bad
um you know but it's like broke it was
the holidays you know
and uh you know so we got a message from
demetri and jen and they're going where
are they back they better be going
downtown sanford is going to be
a [ __ ] show it's not going to be as big
we're going to leave early it's not
going to be as big a [ __ ] show as
downtown orlando is going to be which
i'm sure is just going to be like
[ __ ] bobbed with people it's going to
be fun and the traffic's going to be uh
horrible but and there's gonna be wrecks
well yeah and the cops are gonna be out
and stuff so i mean downtown sanford is
small
so
but it's still kind of a big friday
night and saturday under kind of big
party nights because there's a lot of
bars down there and there's a lot of um
you know like restaurant like bar and
grill type places
so a lot of people do go down there but
but the nice thing about downtown
sanford is that almost all the bars
close
by
11 or midnight although i imagine a lot
of them will be open late tonight so
we'll see
we'll see
yeah david june said uh new year's eve
is amateur night i know right that's
what i always say it's just cuz it's
like that and st patrick's day and cinco
de mayo
it's kind of like everybody just doesn't
really drink all that much the rest of
the year they're like let's go ahead and
get like [ __ ] face and then they're like
pooping themselves in the gutter and
[ __ ] like that it's terrible hugo said
he worked on a bane mask for the movie
wow
i didn't know hugo worked on the movies
but yeah okay well there you go
dj maniac says i ain't going at either
too much money too much traveling and
i'm already in my pajamas we're talking
about all the leather daddies and look
like i'm [ __ ] off the cast of
cruising and [ __ ] yeah
[Laughter]
they'll be at the club
yeah everyone's gonna be there i imagine
from for miles around
maybe he'll probably be there dressed in
his [ __ ] uh black panther
although he might go down where he might
go somewhere else he's probably gonna go
to um downtown orlando i would think
yeah maybe i mean he lives closer to
downtown orlando or at least he used to
i don't that was a while back because i
remember friends if you have a man he
comes up
that's true
so it should be an easier drive but i
told you i was just kind of like you
know we'll go early so we can find some
parking
we usually just park in the dirt like
behind behind mannequins
instead of on the street and uh
hopefully it won't be [ __ ]
uh hopefully it won't be like super
packed and we're gonna have to be really
careful like on the roads and stuff
but it's i mean the drive from here to
mannequins is easy you don't have to go
on the freeway or anything it's a
straight shot there yeah you can just go
right down it's yeah so it's almost it's
not back roads but it's not like freeway
no you know what i mean it's streets
it's not a real
traveled
thing so i figured maybe it'll be okay
maybe it'll be okay
all right so um today is open lines of
course it's uh
new year's anything you guys want to
talk about we're ready to talk about we
can do all the damn topics uh you guys
are interested [ __ ] paranormal
unsolved mysteries [ __ ] you guys have
any questions on [ __ ] anything man uh
tactical [ __ ] uh
uh
just whatever
whatever you guys [ __ ] name we're
just starting to get started we're gonna
have a few drinks okay [ __ ] split we
can't we can't be hanging out with y'all
all night well we were gonna we were
gonna leave around eight
so we could be on for two and a half
three hours yeah we'll be fine yeah i
don't think it'd be that long we're just
trying not to get too [ __ ] up because
you know what i mean
cam guy said you kind of look like a
transformer ooh
camp guy said you kind of look like a
trainer you know what transformer looks
like
[Laughter]
everybody knows what a transformer looks
like what are you talking about he's
making [ __ ] up
oh man uh tila [ __ ] wrestler man like
a like a luchador man
camp guy says mannequins is a great name
for a club
yeah uh yeah and it's kind of
horror themed yeah sort of and this the
old sign i don't remember if it's still
there or not but the old sign used to
have like stills from tourist trap on it
like that you know the creepy mannequins
with their mouths hanging open it had
that and they have all of these like uh
what do they call this there's those
really realistic real dolls yeah they
have a bunch of those like kind of
substances
yeah like with sexy lingerie and stuff
so it's like that's kind of like their
big
uh photo bomb opportunity those things
too man i know can you imagine how many
germs are probably on the titties of
those things because everybody that
comes in is just kind of like oh funny
and then they're just like look i'm
grabbing the titty take a picture yeah
and what's funny is it's the girls doing
it well yeah more than the guys well
yeah because their boyfriends are
probably like hey grab that titty
i've seen single women go in there just
groups of big groups of girls go in
there and just
beat up on the sex dolls and laugh at it
yeah uh betty white died which they were
talking about in the comments before we
started which is kind of a shame i just
saw that like right before we uh right
before we went live i mean she was 99
though
but that's kind of sad that they were
gonna do like this big hundredth
birthday thing and then they were like
ah well [ __ ]
they maybe they should still do it they
should still do it
[Laughter]
okay i got a question from grampus he's
asking if putin goes in hot for a couple
weeks will it be the start of world war
three no not at all
food will go in there and the united
states will talk tough and it'll be
flaccid as a [ __ ] they won't do
anything and when that happens [ __ ]
china will go oh [ __ ] we can do what we
want then and then they'll probably try
to take taiwan
but uh no that's a done deal uh
russia's gonna get about half of ukraine
but
it kind of half of ukraine kind of
belongs to russia anyway i mean the
those
russia's borders changed a lot over over
the hundreds of years
and there's a lot of
ethnic russian people in
in in uh ukraine and evidently the
people that live there it's about 50 50
half of them kind of want to go the
other half want independence depending
on their ethnic background but the us is
going to be able to do anything about it
and when that happens
it's just going to be exposed the u.s is
just the federal [ __ ] government and
it's in the u.s army and the air we have
a decent air force but our armed forces
are in a shitty state of red
readiness uh
we're kind of like a former super power
it just hasn't really trickled down to
the average population yet they don't
realize
the state of readiness which is just not
there
and as soon as that happens
what will start to be questioned next is
uh
why is the u.s dollar the world's
reserve currency
and um
it will start to shift towards the the
yuan the chinese money
that they will probably end up being the
world's reserve currency
because they'll have the military mike
to back things up
uh the only reason why we're
the u.s dollar is the world's reserve
currencies because we have a navy
that can ensure the safety of the dam
oil
chips
well china might want to supplant part
of that so that'll cut about halfway
into the u.s dollar and they've printed
so much of it and it's such a teetering
house of cards it'll just collapse kind
of like brazil's money did when i was
there
but that's the plan that they want that
to happen the oligarchs that run
everything
the u.s is a threat to them and they're
gonna they want a one-world government
they want to collapse everything and
then they'll say see your government's
betrayed you they're inept uh sign on
with us we'll reboot your economy and
make us your government we'll give you a
new constitution and it'll be kind of
it'll be like the chinese social credit
score system that's what they're trying
to do
now will it happen
probably not
they want it to happen but they're
dreaming big
big centralized governments are becoming
a thing of the past they're not
technologically viable anymore
everything is becoming
dissipated and spread out in a network
type society
a good analogy is is that
the old-fashioned top-down centralized
governments are kind of like the
federation from star trek
but the population is more kind of like
the borg from star trek
and they're fighting the borg and they
can't fight the borg
we can print up our own money now
crypto currencies and
the whole concept of government is going
to start shifting
kind of like the whole concept of what
production means
it's just an
the internet's changed everything
technology's changing everything this is
[ __ ] bigger than the down printing
press
bigger than trains and cars
so the oligarchs up top they're trying
to keep control over everything they're
dreaming their wealth is going to vanish
because what they built their empire on
is going away that's why they're so
scared
you know
once their wealth's gone will they be
protected will they be protected for all
the crimes that they committed
no
so they're fighting for their lives
because they've done a lot of weird [ __ ]
all throughout the world
fake wars and stuff
murder hornets nest has a fun question
tom would you rather take it in the bum
by btk or russell williams
i went by with both their asses
that wasn't the question it has to be
one or the other it doesn't it does it's
a false dichotomy that's what the
question was that's a false dichotomy
it's as if it's possible for me to take
it into ass it's not even possible
they're not even any orifices
not even or like a marble statue
like a marvel statue there's nothing
there that's how you heard it here first
time doesn't have a butthole it's like
marvel still it's so early i can't
believe we've started this already yeah
i come like this
that's how i arrived this is how i
arrived right out of the box right out
of the box
like a ken doll but with your butt just
i'm ready for this these kind of
assaults
[ __ ] holy crap
oh holy [ __ ] all right um let's see
oh christ
let's see
i missed like a bunch of stuff because
you were talking for such a long time um
i do what i want to do they ask me a
question i do what i want i do what i
want just like pookie does yeah we got
plenty of time betty white checked out
because [ __ ] lego for saying she
wouldn't be able to play with him
anymore is it because lego was like
uh you know fun for everyone from 9 to
99 or 00 to 99 wasn't that their slogan
that they used to have yeah she's like
when you're 100 [ __ ] you you can't play
with legos anymore yeah
another asked me would i put hundred out
would i put a thousand in silver or
crypto i'd put it in crypto
crypto you can actually spend things you
can buy things let's say you've got a
vpn
i was looking at what you can actually
buy
and crypto
with a vpn that's amazing [ __ ] [ __ ] that
you would normally need a damn
prescription for
well i have a vpn yeah
did did a crypto exchange i didn't get
it to buy legal [ __ ] i just i got it so
i could watch shutter in other countries
because i'm a nerd like that the thing
is
it's questionable whether or not it's
illegal a lot of it just looks like it's
kind of skirting laws well it's one of
those things where you know when they
made the laws they the [ __ ] didn't exist
so they didn't know what they were doing
so you know it's it well it's always
just kind of like the law always kind of
like lags behind the culture as a whole
i mean the cultural evolution is much
quicker so yep you know so they they
don't know what they're gonna do with it
they're gonna have to like sort that out
because it hasn't been around long
enough
for people to sort it out all of the
you know maybe uh unintended
consequences like [ __ ] that's gonna come
out of it so
you know so they're kind of like playing
catch up that's all it is that kind of
always happens i feel like
they can sell you stuff
that are molecules
like this say the testosterone
testosterone incipionate molecule they
can sell you that but it's not in ready
to take form
but if you know what to do with it
which is like
put it into hot [ __ ] grape seed oil
and you know the right measurements you
can inject that but it says all over it
not for human consumption
they'll still sell it to you though
just remember it's not for human
consumption they're like it says they're
right it says right on the bottle if you
do it that's on you that's on you
yeah not for humans we told you not they
got a picture of the damn molecule right
on it
and connoisseurs of that molecule know
exactly what it feels like if you shot
it and you go yeah that's it you know
you go that's it
and you know you can just see right
there
on the uh in the comment sections you
know what i mean this isn't for human
consumption but it is exactly i'm sure
that this is you know they know sure
does feel like it's for human
consumption yeah that kind of [ __ ]
well probably a lot of things do but
that doesn't mean that you should like
do it that's what it is
that's what i was just saying
i'm just saying that's not like general
lacrosse yeah you probably just hey this
like uh this tastes good if i eat it or
you know that's that's not always a good
judge of things you know
well when it comes back positive on the
tests though as that's what the molecule
is you know what it is
gram there's hammer said will you be
stopping by the oasis tonight to
celebrate the new year with the gnarly
bikers no man they'll probably be
[ __ ] killing each other over there
tonight yeah if they start fights every
weekend this is like special new year's
weekends they're like woo now we can get
extra
punchy yeah
they'll be climbing up out of the
woodwork on there tonight that'll be bad
over there tonight that's what i'm
saying so i'm saying yeah it's probably
good that we're leaving early and it's
like just drive very slowly
just be cool
you know i'm glad we don't have to drive
on i-4 because driving on i-4
honestly i will say i know that living
in florida particularly if you live in
central florida
um
for a long time even when i was a kid
i-4 was kind of known as kind of i mean
everyone was there were bumper stickers
every single auto
place that you went to had bumper
stickers set i4 socks on it so like a
lot of people had it because
most of the time
the highways were built at a time
when
central florida wasn't it was populated
but it wasn't all that populated so
i mean i-4 if you don't know is like the
main corridor east-west uh in the
central part of florida
and it's pretty much the main one
and so for a long time all these people
were like moving down to florida and the
road construction couldn't keep up with
the population
you know exploding like from
the 70s onward
so it seemed like it was always in a
state of flux they were always working
on it somewhere and it was always like
this massive [ __ ] and it was
always in the morning and in the
afternoon it was a parking lot and
honestly even a few years back when i
used to have to drive on there every day
to go to work
um
it would take me an hour and a half to
get somewhere that was like 20 minutes
away if there was no traffic
just because you would just go get on an
i4 and you would just sit
because everybody was out there
it's better now because they've actually
done a lot of work that improved it they
widened it they did a lot of um
toll roads uh which is alleviated some
of the you know gridlock so that's kind
of better but it's still
i don't know i still don't like to drive
on i-4 if i can possibly avoid it and
even when you're driving on it like when
we're going downtown even then i'm just
kind of like
like hiding my eyes the whole time
because everybody drives like crazy
people i ran into the guard wheel there
uh one time this is years back
and just because everybody's just bumper
to bumper going [ __ ] 70 miles an hour
and they [ __ ] slam their brakes on
right in front of me and they're all in
these new little like honda fit style
cars that don't weigh anything and i'm i
was in a [ __ ] like a a 95
mustang [ __ ] gt
[ __ ] and all that weight you just
can't stop with those cars
so i just had to [ __ ] go off the road
into the damn safety lane hit the
guardrail
yeah
at least you weren't going fast no i
wasn't going that fast by the time i i
realized i'm not gonna make it by the
time i pulled off i was probably going
about 45 but i would have overshot it by
a good 15 feet rear-ended him and it's
always your fault when you rear-end
somebody it is you know legally they
just go well then you should have been
doing it you know
although i will the one accident i was
in
i did actually rear-end somebody but i
didn't get blamed
it was because
actually they didn't assign a fault uh
to me or to the driver in front because
it wasn't either of our fault it was the
fault of the driver in front of us
who even though the light was green we
were i was in a turn lane on my way to
work the light was green and he just
stopped short
and like so the guy in front of me like
had to stop like that and it's like i
thought everybody was going and i was
you know probably i wasn't speeding or
anything but i just i've hit the guy
why'd he stop he just thought he
couldn't go i'm i don't know i still
don't know um he took off okay so now
the guy in front of me it was an suv and
so his car was
pretty much untouched uh the only thing
that happened was his soda spilled all
over
all over the cabin uh but he was like
yeah that's it my car on the other hand
which an old one was totaled
uh the the first half of it you know the
[ __ ] airbags came out and everything
but at least they didn't blame me though
because i was just saying because the
guy in front of me was just one like the
guy in front of me just like [ __ ]
stopped and the light was green i don't
understand why he just [ __ ] stopped i
don't know if like a [ __ ]
tumbleweed blew across the [ __ ] i don't
know what it was but and i couldn't see
around because the guy in front of me
was an suv so i couldn't see the car
somebody went into the did something to
the intersection somebody pulled out in
front of him or something
i didn't see anybody pull out in front
of anybody i don't know
i don't know like i said i couldn't see
because
in front of me the dude that i hit was
an suv so i couldn't see in front of him
because it was a big ass
suv
so i couldn't see around him i don't
know why the guy in front of him stopped
like that but
he did and i wasn't going super fast i
think i was only going 35 maybe
um
but it still [ __ ] up the whole i mean
the front end of the book you saw it
when you came to the
scene to pick me up
um
yeah it was pretty much like accordion
i was i didn't get hurt though because i
mean
you know i had the airbags
which
i had never experienced being uh being
in a hit a car where the airbags went
off before
i didn't realize that the airbags and i
don't know if it's just because they
were old because this car was super old
the airbags like fill the whole of the
car with like white powder
and it smells really bad
so it's like so i couldn't see for a
really long time like because it just
went poof and that was just like [ __ ]
powder everywhere it was crazy
tila says hubs is out there barbecuing
ooh barbecue will be our meal tonight
that's yeah
i'm kind of hungry still it's like you
know what i mean i guess we ate right
yeah you can get a sandwich down there
yeah we gotta i've got a lot of
carbocation i mean i'll probably have
some i'll probably have a ham sandwich
before we go
we we're gonna need time before we leave
to do things like that get something to
eat get ready
i mean but at least i'm still mostly
ready yeah
i wanted to get ready for we did the
show so i didn't have to like rush
to do it afterward because you know how
that always goes yeah i just feel like i
never have time and then i'd have been
kind of like half drunk and i'd be like
what the [ __ ] i can't i can't find
anything to wear and like i've been
messing the makeup up and all that other
kind of [ __ ] you know what i mean so
what are you looking at me like that for
i know i'd respond to it you don't know
how to respond to that yeah well because
he was probably gonna say something
[ __ ] up and then like
and he's like no i better not say that
[Laughter]
uh who said who got banned for something
murder hornet's nest said i'd upload i'm
on a two-week youtube band
and somebody said what'd you do what'd
you do to get
oh sleazy movies oh okay what you
uploaded some porn to youtube and they
got mad at you who's this
murder hornet's nest
that's pretty funny don't upload porn to
youtube they don't they don't take the i
don't know if he's kidding or not
uh let me see hold on
um strong78 is saying something about
police academy
and then they said they were mad that
you didn't get the reference but i
didn't see what the reference was
because i wasn't looking at the thing
dj maniac has heard of the i4 eyesore
either that or remembers that we
mentioned it it's gone
it's not gone
it's just that the building is done yeah
i don't know if anybody works in there
the outside of the building is done it i
don't think the inside is yeah it might
doesn't it doesn't look like it's not
the eyesore anymore just a building
yeah the reason they call it the i4i
sword was because it took
decades for them to [ __ ] finish it so
it was like for for a long time it was
like halfway up it had glass on the
windows and then like the other half was
just kind of like empty ass
frames the amc theater we go to to watch
these movies so it's right there yeah
it's right there it's right next to it
there's a mall behind it
i can't
ultimately i'm gonna have to look that
up because i can't remember when they
started building that it was building
this game because i remember and maybe
i'm you know maybe this is like [ __ ]
uh anachronistic or whatever but i
thought
that they were building it back when i
was a kid
because i thought i remembered seeing it
when we drove to disney world when i was
little
like in the 70s probably but i could be
remembering it totally wrong it was a
scam it was uh well yeah a church guy
was raising money from all these
churches to build this thing by cash
you know
and he made a whole living collecting
money to build this thing and what it
was going to be it was going to be um
television studios for religious
channels
and it took 30 or 40 years to build that
[ __ ] thing by the time it's done man
television broadcast television is gone
they're like cable televisions well
that's what you get for taking 30
[ __ ] years to finish a building
to basically
do something to [ __ ] do what we do
here which is have a studio in your
house
yeah i mean [ __ ]
there's no reason for television studios
anymore that's scientology they bought
one
they bought all tv studio and all the
[ __ ] equipment and they don't and
they don't need tv nobody watches that
don't they do they still have if anybody
still has cable because we don't um but
i think for a long time they had a
channel like up in the very higher
reaches of
of the cable box you probably all just
uploaded to youtube now
well i think they do that too yeah well
the thing about it is that i mean i
think they they make videos and they're
like well you can upload them to youtube
or whatever but then you can like show
them on your tv network as well because
then that's how you capture your older
audience i guess
you know but the eyesore wasn't stupid
it did work
that guy um died
he lived the rest of his whole life
collecting money for that thing making
[ __ ] a whole living off of building
that building
he died before it was completed
that's all he was doing was just trying
to make a living off of it
and evidently he lived well he had two
or three of his own houses
okay well i guess
we're under the wrong line of work i
suppose yeah you're in the wrong line of
work
go around and just talk to religious
people and give them little speeches and
ask for money and go preach at these
churches and pass the collection plate
around and
pocket about a quarter of it or half of
it
and then the other half you
throw it towards this building you'll
never see completed
you know he was stretching out the
[ __ ]
the the construction time
somebody went in there and did an
analysis had they just borrowed the
money and built it would have been
completed decades ago well yeah it would
have been paid for and would have
[ __ ] you know he would have made more
he would have made money off that too
so you know
well some yeah i i guess
i mean i kind of get that he was just
kind of like well i i want to actually
like not get a loan for this maybe and
like just pay for it
legitimately for parishioners money but
somebody else's money well yeah that's
kind of the way to do it
but it does kind of seem like sometimes
especially for a big project like that
that's way better option
just borrowing the money from the outset
so you can get it built and like put
into use as quickly as possible
he's probably a scientologist
because that's the exact same thing a
scientologist would do
he said they would just milk the whales
for millions and millions and millions
of dollars
build some useless building
and then move on yeah and then you you
kind of like
pocket that part of that money you know
that goes into your foundations and
builds your new other offices
you know
they know what they're doing i guess
really religions have other ways of
making money
strawdog 78 said
i stuck in a i was stuck in a hotel for
a while and stumbled on the scientology
channel weirdly addictive viewing
i imagine it probably would be because
it's so [ __ ] weird
you know yeah oracle says uh tom and
jenny have you heard of marjo gortner
yes i know who marjo gordoner is um
he was that guy
[ __ ] man i kind of he was in some movies
too i think but he was kind of that guy
that was kind of like that evangelist
type of dude i'm like some of the
details are escaping me at the moment
but i remember he was kind of a big
thing i want to say like in the late 70s
something like that he was in some
movies right i think he was in some
movies
was he in
the
what was it called the incredible
two-headed transplant or
i never heard of it did we just i
thought i watched the incredible is was
it the incredible two-headed transplant
or the amazing two-headed transplant i
can't remember i think i watched the
riptrax version of that not too long ago
yeah oracle said he started out as a
child evangelist yeah that's what i
thought yeah he was like a kid
grant there's hammer said jim baker oh
my god is that dude still alive no i
think he's gone and he's gone no well
the gram through hammer said jim baker
sells survival food now he's kind of
bizarre that he pawns freeze-dried eggs
instead of saving souls on tv
tammy faye died though didn't she yeah i
think so cancer
yeah it was it was all that makeup she
wore like i can judge but i'm just
like i'm just saying
yeah i thought he died too but i can't i
don't know i don't remember i don't keep
track of all those people but yeah those
powdered eggs are rough man
they weren't great i gotta say i mean
you had some and you were like well
you're gonna make some trying to figure
out how to make them right to figure out
like how they would best be presented
they're not really best presented
they're just they're edible they're just
edible
but they're not like delicious they have
a weird aftertaste it kind of tastes
like sulfur
remember that weird kind of sulfury
taste that they had yeah
weird i don't know if it was just that
brad
or if they're all like that
honestly i didn't think they tasted
sulfury i just thought they didn't
really taste like much of anything
they got a weird texture
that's true
that's true they didn't i don't really
remember them tasting like much of
anything
yeah janet whoops uh janet pirate says
uh tammy is dead jim is remarried okay
did he
tell me he probably married like a 20
year old i imagine did he i kind of feel
like that sounds like some [ __ ] that he
would do
[Laughter]
i don't know jessica what was the name
jessica what
han jessica hahn isn't that isn't that
the girl's name was that her well see
that's the thing in the 80s there were
so many televangelist scandals that i
can't that i get them confused with one
another yeah
and she ended up on howard stern and she
was looking doing like penthouses and
stuff
i kind of feel like maybe some of those
chicks that might be like kind of a
niche market where they're like hey i'm
gonna i'm gonna seduce this
uh televangelist and then when he gets
outed and [ __ ]
you know the scandal since then i can
like write a book and go on the talk
show circuit and make all kind of money
they just go where the money is you know
yeah
predatory women go where the money is
and there's a lot of it in
churches
there's church groupies
that that's all a grift anyway those
people don't believe in that [ __ ]
janet says i watch a lot of fundy
podcasts she is very young the wife that
he's got yes
uh starbucks 78 said i could have sworn
pat robertson from the 700 club died
decades ago but apparently not now is
that [ __ ] still alive because i thought
he died
recently
but or am i thinking of somebody else
i get them all confused like i said
all those [ __ ]
big old fat con men they all kind of
look all the same yeah
the one i like is the dude that [ __ ]
is always speaking in tongues
the guy over in texas he's about 90 80
and he's
um uh
is benny hen still around not that guy
is robert tilton still around or did he
croak i don't think it's robert tilton i
used to think that guy was really funny
he starts speaking in tongues you know
trying to remember what it is i feel
like a lot of them do that though don't
they because i used to watch them every
now and then like back in the old days
back in like the late 80s and early 90s
like every now you'd be flipping through
and you'd be like oh my god this should
be good and you watch like all these
weird
it's so weird like the [ __ ] that they
and it was so weird like how these
these poor little old people that didn't
have a pot to piss in
you know and then you'd have somebody
like robert tilton it was that whole
what do they call that the [ __ ] um
man there's a name for it where they
where they tell the evangelists like
tell all their fans like hey you have to
robert tilton's big thing was you have
to give out of your need even if you
don't have the money
you have to prove to god that you have
faith by giving me your last ten dollars
and then you'll be reported like you'll
win the lottery or some [ __ ] like that
and
i'm sitting there watching this guy
going how does he [ __ ] sleep at night
like saying that kind of [ __ ] he didn't
believe some of that [ __ ] maybe but
it's just kind of like use it's like
some little old lady somewhere is
probably like eating dog food because of
your stupid ass because she believed
your crap that's like really sad it was
like really sad to me and i was i could
never do that to people but i guess i
guess some people are just sociopaths
prosperity gospel thank you thank you
oracle that's that's the phrase that i
was trying to think of that's not a
uniquely american thing though it's
really big in india with them indian
holy men and [ __ ] years and weird [ __ ]
like that
they do the same thing
tila said they got youtube evangelists
now yeah i figured
i mean
what i think is funny is we'll see we
see europe europeans see that
and the their take on televangelism
that i think it's funny that they think
what is up with america
that [ __ ] is not
not real that [ __ ] is not mainstream
american either it's just those
[ __ ] got their hands on
television commercials well it's always
kind of like they could bought a
television commercial i kind of feel
like well it's kind of station that sort
of works both ways because
i mean
when we say like in the united states if
we see like somebody makes a video like
crazy as [ __ ] from like other countries
a lot of times that stuff isn't stuff
that everyone's doing that's just like
some french guy and it's the same kind
of thing with americans it's just kind
of like
you know what i mean because i saw this
one thing
where that's the dude i'm talking about
oh okay yeah yeah you saw one thing now
what um i saw one thing where people
were talking where it was british people
and they were reacting to like different
things in the u.s but this one video
that this person had made about the us
they're talking about
the american um you know like
restaurants and the food and stuff like
that and i said one
you know and i'm sure most people that
are not from the us know this but i mean
the united states is a massive massive
country so like wherever you go in the
u.s it's not going to be the same
and some of the food that they said
they're like oh my god they have deep
fried everything and i'm like well in
some places they do but most people
don't eat that all the time and some of
the food that they had like deep fried
you know oh they have deep fried um what
was the thing like deep fried twinkies
i'm like nobody eats those yeah it's
like maybe you'd eat it at a fair
in the midwest
or something but nobody eats [ __ ]
yeah nobody eats that like every day we
don't eat like that every day
um mostly we just eat normal ass food
that would be an oddball selection yeah
but so a lot of people like pointed that
out because they're like look like
nobody's eating fried deep fried
twinkies every day they said
maybe i don't think i've ever seen one
i've never seen one um i know they exist
but that's my that's like carnival food
that's like if you were at a county fair
like in the midwest usually like this
midwest or maybe in the south um maybe
you'd get one like for a lark oh my god
a deep fried twinkie holy [ __ ] and then
like you would eat it but
that's not like everyday diet type stuff
and honestly i feel like most but
particularly younger people in the u.s
they don't eat a lot of deep-fried stuff
anymore because it's you know
you do every now and then and people
still eat fast food
i love everybody loves deep fried [ __ ]
because it's delicious but you can't i
mean most people don't eat it every day
though
thank you zach happy new year's peeps
turns out my roomie has the rhona and i
might too but not noticing too much so
far also r.i.p betty white so here's to
2022. thank you very much well i hope
you don't have the rona holy [ __ ]
that would not be good
but yeah so but i found this other
channel too i can't remember his name's
jj something he's canadian
and he did a thing he does a thing about
um i was watching this one it was like
actually kind of fascinating it was only
like 12 minutes but he was talking about
school lunches in other countries which
i thought was really cool
because i mean i haven't been in school
for a long time obviously but i didn't
usually buy lunches at school because
they were
they smelled bad enough i certainly
wasn't gonna eat it so i would always
like bring food from home
but apparently
i mean in the u.s and i think to a large
extent the uk and australia
it's very common for people you know for
kids to like just take a sandwich and
like potato chips or some [ __ ] like that
like candy or something that's very
common but in other countries they
actually um you know particularly like
in scandinavia and stuff they said yeah
nobody brings lunch because the the
school has like a really nice like
cafeteria and it's free and you just eat
like an actual meal like at lunchtime
instead of just like a sandwich or
whatever so it was like really
interesting seeing all the different
countries and then like i was reading
all the comments of the video
and they were telling me it was people
from like all over the world like
talking about what their school lunch
experience was but i'm just saying that
you know it's kind of hard to
generalize i guess across an entire
culture but i do kind of see that but we
do it to other cultures too like if
you've never been there
they were talking about brazil too and i
don't know if this if it was like this
when you were there but they said well
in brazil
most kids
they either do school in the morning
um you know from like 7 a.m to 1 p.m or
they do school in the afternoon so it's
like they don't do lunch at school
because they're usually at home like
they either eat lunch before they go or
they no when i was there yeah but that's
apparently the way it is now but i mean
they're still at school for like five or
six hours but they said there's
there's two different like tracks like
you either go in the morning and then
you're done at one or you go in at like
1 or 1 30 and then stay till 5 or 6.
so you don't actually need that america
you got in the morning you went to
school took a bus
usually your school bus would pick you
up
or
or you walked to your school my school
was private school you know our school
bus would pick us up
and then you were back
you ate lunch there
i don't think you ate breakfast there
they i kind of feel like that maybe
breakfast there i think there was
breakfast yeah i think i just didn't eat
it yeah i think there was breakfast you
could go in there and get some eggs
eggs and biscuits and stuff like that
bacon
but then um
then you had lunch
and then you were home by the time your
parents
you before your parents came home from
work so i guess you were home from
probably around three
yeah 233 so that's about the same yeah i
mean i kind of feel like
i mean and this is going back a long way
because i first started going to
elementary school in the 70s
elementary school which when i was a kid
was kindergarten through sixth grade and
they changed that later
uh to become just kindergarten to fifth
and that was 9 a.m to 3 p.m
junior high which was grade 7 8 9
that was 8 20 a.m to 2 40 p.m
in high school which was
uh
only 10 11 12. now it's 9 10 11 12.
high school was 7
30
to 2 30 i think
if i'm remembering correctly
but they i don't know they experimented
with different things so i thought that
was kind of interesting that like some
countries apparently including brazil
nowadays they said most most kids in
brazil either do five hours in the
morning or five hours in the afternoon
so you don't actually eat at school
because you always eat at home
um
i kind of feel like when i was going to
school they had lunch and i
always took mine
because you know the caf they had stuff
in the cafeteria but it never really
smelled all that appetizing so i would
just take a sandwich or whatever
but
but when i was younger maybe when i
started like junior high or something
like that which they call middle school
now um they started doing breakfast just
because so many kids like were kind of
below poverty level and didn't have
but so they would do free breakfast but
it wasn't anything good it wasn't like
eggs and [ __ ] it was just kind of like
here's a little box of frosted flakes
and a little yeah and a little thing of
milk hey grandpa's in it
because we went to high school in in
michigan together for a while i went to
high school both in michigan and brazil
at trenton didn't they have didn't they
have breakfast there i think they did
didn't they
didn't they give out those little damn
boxes of cereal and a milk been so long
i kind of yeah they did that where i was
too yeah i don't know if that was for
certain hours only certain people got
that i don't remember what
but i kind of think that you could go in
there and get a milk and those little
boxes of cereal
and maybe something like grits
or in michigan it probably would have
been oatmeal
yeah i don't think they i think they
would give you a box of cereal a carton
of milk and maybe like an apple or a
banana yeah [ __ ] like that like they had
like fruit but what was funny is that
you know
this was middle class upper middle class
upper class in brazil i went there and i
went to a [ __ ] school with just rich
people you know
and uh
they had all that food and it still
wasn't even very good
you know well the thing well if it's a
school they're just kind of like well
kids aren't real discerning i guess so
they're just gonna like we're just gonna
have bottom of the barrel stuff that's
just barely edible yeah
and it was all like you didn't have any
choices this is what you're getting
basically you know i mean like there
wasn't any
selections although the lunch is all
right they had it was usually stuff like
sliced real thinly sliced beef i forgot
what they call that with rice and beans
and i remember that they were always
given milanesa chicken melon which is
you take a chicken breast which and you
pound they pound it out flat bread and
fry it which is weird but it's a
brazilian thing it's like fried boneless
chicken [ __ ] beaten out
um it loses its flavor
i think when they do that they overcook
it
yeah but
probably because it's easy to cook
quickly and large
yeah and it cooks quickly because
there's no bones in it it's thinned well
that's kind of why you see you know
particularly school lunches in the us
and the uk and stuff like that you
usually see stuff like thank you again
zack
um
you usually see stuff like spaghetti or
pizza or burgers or something like that
because it's like really easy to make in
large quantities yeah uh zach says thank
you very much by the way my high school
was 745 to 255 of all things yeah ours
was kind of similar
i think the zero talents tolerance
bullying no child left behind policies
from the bush obama years really messed
up schooling more than helped for a lot
of kids i don't well i can't really
speak to that because i was already out
of school by then
but some people like i said it was kind
of interesting to me to see
the stuff about
particularly somebody posted uh in the
comments of that video that i was
watching
somebody that was from sweden
and they said well i'm still in
secondary school so there so they gave
an example he's like here's the menu for
this week and he's like they always have
they serve it buffet style it's free you
can come in and eat and uh nobody brings
anything because the food is actually
pretty decent so they had so they have
something different every day so it's
kind of like they have a meat option and
they have a vegetarian option or vegan
option so you can have like one of the
two things but all the stuff that they
had they like they had indian food they
had tacos they had all different kind of
stuff and most of it sounded like pretty
good to be honest with you all right um
graham said that only kids from section
8 housing got the breakfast at trenton
high okay that's why maybe yeah i don't
know if it's a universal it might be now
because like i said it's been a long
time trenton it was just it was yeah i
kind of feel like where i was it was
kind of piecemeal like some people got
it like if you were poor right um you
just like you'd get reduced if you i
think if you qualified for reduced price
or free lunch because you know you had
those tickets then i think you could get
breakfast too if you wanted it we had he
he mentioned we had open campus so we
were always going to like mcdonald's and
little caesar's next door we did that
too and the thing is is that i lived
less than a block away from school so i
just walked home
yeah walked home and ate it at home so
yeah when i was in high school
um i lived yeah like a less than a
five-minute walk from my school
but um
but there was nobody home like so i
didn't feel like sometimes i would go
home and cook something but it was
usually just like [ __ ] noodles or
some [ __ ] or some soup out of a can but
what we would usually do me and my
friends because we had open campus too
so you could there was a mcdonald's
a pizza hut
and then there was like an eckerd drug
so you could get if you just wanted
because sometimes i wasn't that hungry
or i didn't have any money so i would
just go in eckerd's and get like some
[ __ ] candy like not candy but like
crackers or something or you know some
lame [ __ ] like that but most people like
i think if you were a senior maybe if
you were a junior you could leave
sophomores couldn't
but you were allowed to leave so every
now and then
you know because people we this high
school i went to was right across from
the beach yeah right across the atlantic
ocean so sometimes
in the spring
uh you know people during the lunch
period they'd wear bathing suits under
their clothes and they would go over
yeah and lay out in the sun for
for 40 minutes or whatever and then come
back to school yeah for europeans you
guys would trip on america high school
it is like it wasn't a move
again juniors and i think it was juniors
and
seniors had cars
and apartments i was filled with [ __ ]
cars i was telling a chinese woman
online she was saying she was common she
was making videos remember that remember
that through my eyes remember that
[ __ ] video oh yeah i remember she's
[ __ ]
videotaping her her daughter's high
school
and she says in there i don't know who
all these cars were and i commented this
those are the students cars yeah and she
wouldn't believe me
i said no
you start driving when you're like 16
17.
she she well 15 you can get your
learner's permit yeah yeah i think i
think i had a permit
i think we got how old were we grabbed
us when we got that got that permit so
that old dude who taught us how to drive
[ __ ] looked like a damn
alligator and a tie he had a tie and he
had a face look like an alligator then
big old glasses okay now you're gonna
drive right
don't do anything crazy
[Laughter]
i think i was about 15
when i got that permit either 15 or 16.
i'll be driving around and it was dark
man because we were doing that [ __ ]
before school was open and in michigan
[ __ ] that meant was dark
you know we'd show up there at like 5 30
in the morning
you know and we had we were driving for
a couple hours before school started i
remember that [ __ ]
well yeah especially high school and i
mean you guys high school probably like
our high school started really early
yeah it's real early so i was really
glad that we lived so close because i
didn't have to wake up at the [ __ ]
ass crack of dawn every day
yeah
yeah hugo said 15 years old in texas for
a permit yeah as far as i know where it
was when i was a kid it's 15 in florida
too uh you matthews that's right mr
matthews
16. yeah you can get a permit here at 15
which means that you can drive but you
have to have an older licensed driver in
the car with you and you're technically
not supposed to drive at night unless
you're going to or from work then it's
allowed
um but i don't know the rules might have
changed since then but that's what it
was when i was
getting so but when you're 16 you can
take the test and get your regular
license
so
and i'm gonna say yeah a lot of high
school students juniors and seniors do
have cars i did not
um cause i was broke ass but uh and a
lot of other students didn't as well but
like i said i lived within walking
distance man
in michigan and trenton that's looking
motor city that's that's detroit that's
outside detroit most people's parents
had something to do with making those
cars
you know they were executives or
something you know they worked for one
of those [ __ ] ford or
chevy or somebody they worked for
something like that and all their kids
had cars you could get a used car there
for nothing i bought a [ __ ] merc a 72
mercury montego for 250 dollars rattle
trap and and i drove it for about six
months
until until the transmission went out
and i [ __ ] just jumped it and then
looking back on it it was just low on
transmission fluid i just thought
well you don't know when you're a kid no
it was just low on transmission fluid
that's all it was i remember my brother
bought like a
baby blue ford pinto it was old for 200.
he had it for about a week and it
essentially exploded yeah so you know
you get what you pay for dad i remember
bad ass cars at trenton high
[ __ ] dudes with [ __ ] uh brand new
ford tauruses
uh they were they were brand new back in
those days and uh
guys in buick grand nationals the
[ __ ] with the turbocharged [ __ ]
grand national
uh corvettes
a lot of [ __ ] pontiac firebirds and
iraq z's
fieros remember them [ __ ] things
fiero that we thought that was a dab
like a ferrari
little bitty fiera
they were pieces of [ __ ] man but we
didn't know they were brand new
and they some of them girls were driving
around those geo metros
remember that
you you better i kind of remember those
yeah a little bitty three-cylinder car i
think it was three cylinder
tila said same uh same learning permit
policy in california uh yeah i'm pretty
sure that that's i don't think it's
standard across the nation but i think
that's probably pretty standard like
across most of the states and i don't
really see any reason for them to have
changed it because it seems pretty
reasonable see gravity's coming at me
with this sideways [ __ ]
okay he's coming question for tom did
steve's basement love motel get much use
during the trenton high lunches
no that was too far away
we went to my house
[ __ ] uh
not even five minute walk you know where
the rock was you smoke cigarettes next
block over on the corner
i guess the neck next block just
200 meters that's where my house was
so we all went over it was so easy yeah
200 meters so if you wanted to go bang
your girlfriends during the lunch hour
then you can take the girls down there
we'd [ __ ] get something to eat make
out you never could tell what would
happen i had a guest bed and everything
i did
house had a guest bedroom
[ __ ] all kinds of [ __ ] kicky [ __ ]
happened in there
did it really or you did or you just
like
[Laughter]
that's why he's asking
it was
the 80s were a better time
now i think
and i don't know and it was
shannon high was good people very good
people
maria says he's asking about mary lynn
that's what he's doing oh he's slick
he's all the slick he's asked about it
maria said the guys i went to high
school with drove their farms pickups
during the winter when their dads didn't
need them so much until they needed to
haul hay out to the cattle in the snow
yeah
that's
honestly like i
where i went to high school was
um
it wasn't like a rich rich neighborhood
but most of the kind of like upper
middle class kids went there
so
i don't know i don't know how much
percentage of the senior class had cars
but a lot of them did
i never had one though but i always had
friends that had cars so i always had
somebody to cart my ass around so that
was always nice yeah graham's talking
about how
pretty much people's parents back in
those days at that place and
in trenton they were they were
management or upper management in in the
uh in the automotive industry so
everybody got sweet deals on cars
um my best friends
steve his dad was uh
ford executive he was someone and he was
one of these dudes in marketing you know
and he was constantly
getting free cars to just drive they
would just give him a car
and uh i remember he got a uh
now
it wasn't really his per se it was like
a company car he had to give it back
right
you know
i remember he had that damn ford turbo
coupe when that came out and then they
had the super coupe which is there's a
turbo charge well first to start out
with a super coupe that was supercharged
and then he came a couple months later
he had the turbo coupe that was a
turbocharged version
uh he drove that for a while and then he
had a um
a ford taurus
but this is like one of the very
it was that same ford taurus that
[ __ ] robocop was driving another
movie robocop and me and me and uh steve
were tripping the [ __ ] out because when
that movie robocop came out
the ford taurus had not been released
yet i don't believe that was a prototype
that ford had had shoehorned into that
movie so everybody could see it
and his dad got one of the first ones
very big it was just like look at he's
got the robocop car
and then that was then that vanished and
then he came back with a [ __ ] merkur
i think it was a
which was like a german ford
and that thing was bizarre
and then he came back with a [ __ ]
that must that new ford mustang gt
fastback
he had that for a while then he got
divorced and then we saw him with a new
woman that was that was a story too
that's the trip there
i think i told that story already yeah i
remember that yeah
thank you david june
i want to see bane in the judge wig i
have a feeling it would be worth a dumb
laugh no
what do you mean no i'm not in the mood
for you it was a super chat i'm not i'm
not in the mood for the uh
right now man i'm drinking
well when you finish your drink you get
a job you just do it for a second just
do it for a second
[Laughter]
it'd be funny i'll do it later man i
just i don't know if it's because we
have the i turned the um
the what do you call it the ceiling fan
on earlier because it was like kind of
hot in here and it's just it's making my
eyes water
like and i'm trying to go like this so
it doesn't [ __ ] my makeup up so i don't
have to start over thank you again zach
you see graham saying we were barking
like rabbits in the 80s kids today today
kids today do not know what they were
missing they don't
there was something about that place and
time granters it was like
it was better than the 1960s man that it
was [ __ ] free love
i think it was just that town and at
that time of the eighties i think that's
what it was it had to do with control
didn't have anything better to do
no it's because
everybody's parents had money because
they were working in that auto industry
before it collapsed
so it was that was a great neighborhood
a grantors will attest that was like
some [ __ ] straight out of the back of
the future that was like where marty
mcfly lived just like that
it was just 100 pure americana
it was pure
kind of middle class upper middle class
americana was like something out of a
death spielberg movie
i heard it's not look quite like that
like it like it was but
it's still there i guess but
it was just
it was a good place to be at that time
so uh thank you zack zack says my high
school was so big when one of the seven
minute passing periods came up i'd have
to run so much i still have huge calf
muscles six years later uh yeah i kind
of feel like well i think we only got
five minutes in between
of the classes
and so my high school wasn't that huge
but it was still kind of a challenge
to get all the way uh to your next class
you know what i mean and honestly i it's
really weird because sometimes i would
see
um
you know you see a lot of american
movies that are set in high schools and
all of the high schools
in the movies are like
inside a building
and our high school was not like that
like obviously the classrooms were
inside duh
but
because it's florida
all the hallways are outside so they're
all like sidewalks
so basically it's just kind of like
sidewalks and then there'd be like doors
on the outside it looked kind of like a
roadside motel to be honest with you
maybe maybe like a little bit classier
than that but
most of it was outside because it's
florida and the weather's nice so that's
why we didn't have these big like inside
buildings i think they used to because i
think an elementary school i went to
briefly when i was really little back in
the 70s that was all enclosed like a
more old school one like or one up north
would be
but
i don't even think that's a school
anymore it might not even be there
anymore i'm not sure i don't think it's
school anymore though
one of the little spikes came unscrewed
the screw's still there
let's see where were we okay so i got
behind
so now they're talking about different
cars
maria said i was in my 20s in the 1980s
am i your oldest audience member no
um not by much probably it didn't matter
uh yeah i was um let's see
i was born in 1972
so i graduated from high school in 1990
so i was almost in my 20s in the 80s
i was born in 69 so yeah
so you might be you're not so you might
not be the oldest you're like a little
bit older than us but that's but not by
much i don't think
so but i mean you graduated a couple
years before me
but i was i turned 18 in 1990 and i
graduated from high school in 1990.
mary connolly said i graduated in 1972.
so that's um
[Music]
i don't say this to make you feel bad
but that's uh that's my parents age
that's my parents graduated in 1972. and
they also had me in 1972.
[Laughter]
so you know there was that oh you might
be pretty old
[Laughter]
well you're my you're my parents age yep
my mom and dad were both born in 1954
and
they're my mom's in her 60s now
and she's still
she's still in good shape
you know i just went and saw her the
other day so that was like pretty cool
but yeah she graduated in 1972. and then
she she graduated in may of 1972 and
then she had me in september of that
same year so there you go
david june said makes me wonder
who the youngest audience member is now
i'm kind of i'm sure you got teenagers
coming in through here tammy said i'm
53.
okay so you're
like tom's age yeah
oh
jesus christ what are you doing he makes
me so nervous he's always like knocking
things over and making noise and because
you're high strung [ __ ] like that i'm
not high strong i didn't used to be high
strung until i've hung out with you all
the time then i'm always kind of like
what are you doing
honestly like before we started
pookie has a thing where she comes in
here
and if you're not paying enough
attention to her she'll
she sneaks up behind the chair and jumps
up on the arm of the chair and whenever
she jumps on something she always makes
up
noise yeah that's her world of warning
sound yeah so it's like well it's too
late then because it's just kind of like
so basically it's like and then she
appears and i'm just like holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] you just get the hell out of me and
then she tried to jump on here
and i was trying to get her to not jump
on the keyboard so she grabbed at the um
the mouse pad and then she was like
scrabbling like this and she knocked all
the [ __ ]
uh
shot glasses over and she was like
knocking everything over and she was
like oh my god oh my god and then like
she grabbed my leg like she thought she
was gonna [ __ ]
fall 20 stories or something i'm like
dude baby the floor is right there
you're fine
you're fine
uh let's see um grant there's hammer
said question any new year's resolutions
like only three drinks per sidetracks
episode that's not gonna happen i'm
gonna make i'm not gonna make that
resolution honestly
i don't know um
usually the only thing i do around new
year's is i try to think of
what like projects i want to get
accomplished this year i don't really
call them resolutions i guess but i'm
just kind of like well before the end of
the year i'd like to get this book
finished and this other thing finished
and that kind of stuff
but
if i don't i don't feel too bad about it
i try not to get too
wrapped up in that because i know how
people
are just kind of like i'm gonna change
my whole life this year i'm gonna like
lose 50 pounds and i'm gonna like do
this and that's the other thing and then
they don't do it and then like they feel
like [ __ ] about it so
you can do that anytime anyway it
doesn't have to be new years but i get
that it's kind of you know it's kind of
nice to have a thing that's like a reset
but
that's usually all i do so all i've done
is
oh for next year i have like one book i
want to finish and i have another game i
want to finish
and just like a couple other little
[ __ ] projects i want to do
but i'm trying not to strain myself too
much because
i don't know i feel like i have a
tendency to like overextend myself
because i have like all these million
ideas and
ah
and then i always like feel like a loser
if i can't get them all done but i'm
just kind of like well
i need to just like pick up one or two
and like focus on those instead of
trying to spread myself out over like 50
000 different projects just because
everything seems like a good idea
because that's my problem i think is
that
i have so many
cool ideas and i'm just kind of like
that i think i'm just like oh man i
should do
this that the other thing and then like
i write all this these notes about it
it's like let's do this and i sort it
all out and then i get bummed out
because i'd never get around to it
because i don't have time you know it's
just kind of that situation so i'm
trying to like not yeah i'm trying to
not beat myself up about
about not like finishing all this stuff
so i basically i have one book i want to
finish i have one game i want to finish
i was like if i get other stuff done
then that's just gravy but i feel like
last year i was just kind of like i made
this big list of like all this stuff i
wanted to do and i got a lot of it done
to be fair but
some of it i didn't get done and then
this year i'm just like [ __ ] it i'm not
doing all that because if i hadn't done
it like in the past year i'm probably
not going to do it so
yeah let's see
uh dave's web space telescope
oh did it yeah it's uh
moving out towards position it seems to
be going
pretty uh good so far
it's got a uh
i think in a couple weeks it's gonna
get out further and then start extending
the little um
the mirrors
for the lens for all the lenses yeah
it's all robotics got to unfold
but we won't be getting any pictures
from it for about another six months
yeah i kind of feel like they see that
this thing is [ __ ] fantastic you know
it's um
so good that it'll be actually be able
to see the atmospheres of [ __ ]
exoplanets
some of the near
exoplanets
that'll be neat yeah so you might
actually imagine a planet
and some people were saying you might be
able to if there was anything that had
city lights you'd probably be able to
see it
wouldn't that be something yeah
that'd be super cool if that happened in
this year yeah
it's like hey we found this planet look
there's like all these little like
[ __ ] lights yeah
the chances of anything little aliens
going hey
[Laughter]
i know but don't don't like suck the fun
out of everything you know how you do
uh mary says do i go straight i guess
you're asking me uh no i don't it's just
because i've thought about it but then i
was just kind of like man i have so many
projects of my own that i want to do
it's like i really
don't want to have to like write
somebody else's stuff
i have thought about doing just like for
extra money like as a side gig i have
thought about doing um like audio
transcription because they always need
people to do that
and you know
they're looking for people that are like
really good at grammar and [ __ ] like
that
so i don't know i might look into doing
that for extra money but that's about it
i don't i i just have too many projects
in my own that i want to do to like get
involved in other people's stuff
um captain blair said if you each could
have any arcade cabinet video game you
want for the home
what would it be
now i mean
i know what you're gonna say it's like
well because nowadays you can have an
arcade with like 500 games on it so you
can have all the games i think it means
classic but if you want yeah if you
could just have one game
like in a cabinet which one would it be
oh that's hard
there's a couple of them out there you
know what i'm probably gonna say oh
there's a couple i'm probably gonna say
miss pac-man because honestly every time
i go
no because every time i go to a bar like
i said will's pub used to have a miss
pac-man machine in there and every time
i see the miss pac-man machine i always
get like really excited and i'm just
like ooh like i like some other classic
games too i like centipede a lot i like
joust i liked burger time i like like
all those really kind of weird ones but
miss pac-man was the one that i played
consistently like a lot in the 80s and
i'm still fairly good at it
so i'd probably get miss pac-man
i don't know
there was a um
there was a version of alien i think it
was called aliens with and it had it had
the gun and the aliens would be out in
front of you it was a shooting game
that one was pretty good from what i
remember
um
another one that i really liked was it's
cheesy by today's standards but i think
it was called um
operation
operation what was it
operation wolf i think is what it was
called had it you had the uzi
and it was a scroller scrolling [ __ ]
game you were shooting you're in vietnam
it was called operation wolf i don't
remember that one yeah it's pretty good
um
but then again you know there's also a
defender
and then i think defender two i think
was called stargate wasn't it
i don't know yeah hugo said defenders
yeah and somebody said stand
you're gonna get butthorn rastan wasn't
that good though
it was it was
for a while there in the 80s those uh
cabinets would come out
and you could wear them out you know in
a couple of days if you had the money
you could you could beat them
and then they weren't quite as fun to
play again but some were real
repeatable you know you could play them
over and over again like i remember
gauntlet
that if if you had multiple players you
could play gauntlet forever and that was
like a dungeons and dragons kind of
shooter game
um
trying to think of some other good ones
oh [ __ ] yeah i'm trying to i don't know
like i did actually used to play a lot
of the cabinet video games back in the
80s because that was what you did you
just had your mom would drop you off
with a big bag full of quarters
and you just hang out in the mall all
day like at the [ __ ] arcade
there was one called akari warriors
now i kind of remember that one yeah
it was two guys could play side by side
and had joysticks and had a rotating
tops on them and two buttons one for
fire and one was for grenades
and you had two guys and they had
[ __ ] bandanas they got little rambos
and they you had to run forward and it
would scroll
the screen would scroll down you're
looking down on it
and you're just fighting damn aliens and
you have to go to hell and
fighting these giant monsters and just
being swarmed by these little bitty
green humanoids we call them [ __ ]
zimbabwes they've been saying goes
so we just call them zip weebies
and steve made that [ __ ] name up but
the grantors knows exactly what that
crazy he was look at little simply you
know just he it was just [ __ ] funny
and we just had to like
you had to pick you could change weapons
by depending on what you picked up
and off the top of my head
you could if you got like the same
weapon two or three times and power up
if you had maximum power flamethrower
as the main weapon and then you had like
the red grenades that exploded through
the shrapnel
uh that was like the best combination
you had two dudes with the [ __ ]
powered up flamethrowers and the
shrapnel grenades
you could [ __ ] you could tear them up
you could get swamped the whole waves of
[ __ ]
and you could hold them back
because when they said when you set us
in we'd be on fire it would run away
screaming i like how you're just calling
that like
that
that's what they're called they were
[ __ ] hard to kill because there were
so many of them they were weak but they
were i mean anybody got a band out there
there's a bad name for you
[Laughter]
like little babies
they did they got little green little
babies
coming at you
but they would just kill their babies i
like it yeah they were they were like
little plant babies
um green
and uh maybe i don't remember this game
yeah i would i would have remembered i
would have remembered little green plant
babies i'll show it to you
because
it might bring some memories on youtube
somebody play the whole game on youtube
cause somebody scream capture the whole
game because like i said i used to i i
mean me and my little brother i have a
brother that's four years younger and
you know we used to [ __ ] hang out at
arcades all the time yeah so i mean i
had specific games that i liked that
were my favorites but i played like a
bunch of different ones but some but the
ones that i didn't play that often i
kind of forgot
see the good thing about the
flamethrower
in akari warriors is that if you
shot a zimbabwe with flat
flame it would run from you
and it would be on fire when it would
run and it if it touched another zombie
we'd be catching that one on fire well
yeah i mean but i only think it would do
it once oh so you know i mean you
couldn't
you couldn't just like
so
they come at you and you can you know
two rambos side by side what could get
any better you're in the 80s and
everybody looks like rambo and you're
[ __ ] in a video game yeah you got
everybody's room you got a black wife
beater on like you have right now but
you have a mullet yeah and then they had
and you go oh
yeah one the only difference between the
two is one had a red bad dan and the
other blue bandanna
see i remember that but i don't remember
like little green babies
tila said jenny i think horror erotica
would be a really cool sub-genre to get
into i thought about that for a while
and i actually wrote
a couple of kind of like short stories
along that line that i kind of sold as
e-books for a while um but then i don't
know i just kind of like i have a thing
where it's just after a while i kind of
like
i get all like gung-ho about something
and i do it for a little while and then
i'm like okay i'm bored so i have to
like move on to something else i have
like [ __ ] 80d probably maria said
what was the one that you had to jump
over holes and rocks
you know what i know exactly what you're
talking about was it pitfall yeah yeah
that's on the top i was going to say i
remember that one yeah
kevin's talking about tron battle zone
star trek
star wars
space wars those are the old space work
mary says does anyone remember pong yeah
yeah honestly um my family was to like
my aunt and uncle they were like had
more money than us
so they had pong when it first came out
we had
i feel like a little while later we had
the odyssey system which was like the
knockoff atari it was like way cheaper
and it had a version of pong but i can't
remember what it was called it wasn't
called pong because that's obviously
trademarked
uh thank you zach i always thought it
was weird how we read basically
everything in english classes but not
screenplays as if that's not a form of
writing i kind of well i mean that might
change um
yeah but actually absolutely like
screenplays are just as legitimate just
like you know [ __ ] even nowadays like
graphic novels and stuff like that i
think for a long time people [ __ ] on
those who are like oh it's just comic
books that's for kids but
a lot of those are just as [ __ ]
deep and [ __ ] like that as a [ __ ]
novel so i don't really understand it's
all literature people yeah i mean
about it contra
contra was all right i wasn't i wasn't a
huge fan of contra remember our type
one where you're like this little
jet flying through the inside of a human
body you're like [ __ ] miniature i
don't remember that one yeah but that
and that's that sounds like it would
have been right up my alley too yeah
it's kind of like kind of like fantastic
voyage you get attacked by all these
[ __ ]
and you know [ __ ] viruses and stuff
but they also were like robots
and you're like a little ship but you
you had little sonic scalpels and you're
fighting it's just a game you know
and he's talking about moon patrol i
didn't move patrol oh i liked moon
patrol when it came out moon patrol was
a trip because it had good it had good
uh graphics
but i think it got supplanted by phoenix
and pleiades those two games remember
phoenix phoenix had the music
head for elise would be playing in it
and if you [ __ ] shot the damn bird's
wing and just grow another one you had
to shoot him in the middle what about
satan's hollow remember that one i
thought you were going to say satan
something else
[Laughter]
satan's hollow
that's a good one about firebird
it was a good one kind of like satan's
health somebody brings up frogger
actually i quite liked frogger as well
but honestly that one kind of stressed
me out it's called space firebird not
firebird space firebird i haven't seen
that in a long time
that's kind of a dumb name though space
space firebird
it was kind of like galaxians but it had
better graphics okay
i mean you have on your xbox you have
you have all those old arcades i have
all the williams arcades oh okay it has
satan's hollow and it doesn't have it
doesn't have uh
um
uh
didn't have phoenix or uh pleiades or
saxon
remember zaxon
yeah i kinda it's one weird i remember
seeing that in the in the yeah i
remember seeing that in the arcade all
the time it's kind of like the first
attempt at 3d
but you're not it's not first person
right
it's funny
i kind of feel like well
i don't know like all these old video
games and stuff
it's kind of this is why
like i know people like get older people
like us be like back in my day blah blah
but honestly this is why today is better
because honestly today if you want to
play like cool badass video games that
came out recently you can play those and
if you want to play the old ones you can
also play those yeah and it's just like
and the older ones were harder
everything's available because you have
like a [ __ ] ton of like old video games
old games were all about timing and
there was they were super unforgiving if
you couldn't get the jumps right you
couldn't get the times right you just
died [ __ ] can we talk about it was two
dimensional can we talk about dragon's
lair for a second yeah another
impossible one
did anybody get anywhere in that game if
you guys didn't know like if you didn't
grow up in the 80s dragon's lair was the
first one that was like it was animated
like a cartoon it was a video laserdisc
game right um
honestly yeah and it's just like i used
to play it and it was more expensive to
play than the other games i think it was
like 50 cents instead of a quarter
so every now and then i'd be like man
i'm gonna get it i'm gonna do it this
time so you'd put 50 [ __ ] cents in
there out of your like little handful of
quarters and then literally you'd have
the little dude in your little cartoon
and he would go in the first little room
and i'd be like okay and i'll go this
way oh he's dead because
you're watching it instead of commanding
it and it something would flash and he
had to like press everything was just
directional right left up down jump you
just saw you know it was hard i could
never figure out what you were supposed
to do it's on the i think it's on the
williams arcade you get and it's it's
if you're not paying you realize how
much money you'd be blowing on on that
how hard that game is now there was
another laserdisc game called firefox it
was after that damn
oh yeah i remember that movie yeah
it was good there was nothing but just a
bunch of aerial footage of flying and
then superimposed over little jets jets
and rockets
and it was good it's just i don't know
what happened to it
it was fun to play though david jun
points out this is probably a good point
old games were harder because they were
designed to eat quarters yeah yeah
they made a [ __ ] ton of money out of
that stuff for for a minute there
they had one that came out i [ __ ]
loved it was called strider it was all
be this [ __ ] little japanese anime
superhero he could run and chop and he
had a blades and i think he could pick
up guns it was it was fun to play
strider
gran there's hammer ass where did tom
play arcade games in trenton the bowling
alley or 7-eleven
both no no 7-eleven and then um
me jason and um steve would go to um
this was our like friday night
um
before uh before the [ __ ] girl action
got super hot and heavy now girls gotten
away with all that got got in the way of
god damn it those girls get in the way
of their video games yeah
but we still worked it out
yeah
we worked
video rental place what was a
blockbuster
this is over there near [ __ ] taylor
remember where all the taylor billy
girls were
i think it was over near taylor that's
what i think that's where the uh
there were
no excuse me
that's not where we went no we we went
to the we went to taylor to go to the
arcade
you might remember what the name of that
place was
there's an arcade right on the edge of
taylor there
it was it was pretty big
from what i remember they had like
[ __ ] space harrier
they had narcs remember that game narcs
they had that they had blasteroids they
had uh they had akari warriors we were
[ __ ] tearing up akari warriors in
there um
[ __ ]
trying to think they had other other
but those are the main ones that we were
playing at that time
akari warriors
and uh
cancer's probably remember where
maria says there's a couple of youtubers
who do songs in 8-bit men without hats
safety dance yeah
riot
yeah there you go it's called steve's
arcade [ __ ] it was a big red barn and
[ __ ] tail that was it it actually
it kind of looked like a pizza hut or
something to me that kind of remembered
but yeah that bar that was it
you know what you said
uh i was reading a comment okay maria
said there's a couple of youtubers who
do songs in 8-bit men without hats
safety dance and 8-bit is a riot so is
toto's africa oh i can imagine
i can imagine
yeah i can hear safety dance in 8-bit i
can imagine it
uh mike tyson's punch-out somebody
points out
yeah uh yeah uh chat was on sega on
nanosega it was on um nintendo was it
yeah pretty sure it was on i don't think
we had that we had nintendo and we had
a sega yeah
later but you had to fight glass joe
okay we was the first we didn't have
that yeah we had i heard of it but we
didn't have it what did we have we had
like a game it was hard yeah it was just
kind of like we had um we had tetris we
had metroid
zelda yeah metroid was good we had mario
kart that was super fun me and my
brother used to play that and try to run
each other off the road all the time um
castlevania i really liked castlevania
like back in the old nintendo days
another good one for uh that we that we
had for uh
uh
nintendo's nes it was a master blaster
you had a little tank that could jump
and come out of the tank it could fight
it was kind of like metroid but you're
doing it from a little tank
and you upgrade the tank to work you can
fly or you upgrade the tank and it could
swim and it did all kinds of cool [ __ ]
good little game
yeah we weren't red for a second but i
think it's coming back okay it's coming
back
um
yeah the nes dragon's lair gives me
nightmares right it's just
how do you play it dj maniac said i have
a dvd version of the space ace game
designed by the same company they did
dragon's lair and even on dvd it's
[ __ ] impossible okay well i don't
feel bad then
because i used to every now and then i
would have some quarters i have some
extra quarters and i'd look at dragon's
lair and i'd be like [ __ ] i'm gonna
figure out
like i'm gonna i'm gonna get
far in this we'll see so i put 50 cents
in there and again like two seconds in
i'd be like what he's dead like i don't
understand i would try something
different like every time and nothing i
did worked so i'm just like how the [ __ ]
do you even do this and then after a
while i thought is this like a scam just
to like take your buddy
is it through it
you can get through it you just have to
understand how the controls work
and you have to do it from his point of
view or your point of view it depends on
well i got that but it just seemed like
nothing of like i said it has to be just
right sometimes i know i know where he
has to go has to flash and you have to
hit it just right you hit it too soon
you die if you hit it too late you die
it's well that's probably it is hard it
is hard because i know how controls work
i've been playing video games my whole
life but it's just kind of like the
controls on that are not like any other
game because they're just not there's no
feel to that game everything's
everything is
timing and commands he's doing it not
you you know what i mean it's not the
same yeah i i hated that game i like to
watch it but i didn't like to play it
it's just
i just remember it being like a really
big deal because it was kind of like ooh
it was way ahead of the curve because
it's like it was animated so it's almost
almost like you were playing a cartoon
so back in those days everybody was just
like holy [ __ ] this is like some
high-tech well they made you think you
were playing a cartoon it was really
more like you were just controlling a
[ __ ] dvd player pretty much that's
all you were doing yeah but we weren't
thinking in those terms at that time
like now everybody would be like big
[ __ ] deal i don't care a lot of those
games don't have the same thrill because
you understand the format now
you know yeah in those days you weren't
sure how a game would end you weren't
really like sure the the format wasn't
very predictable you weren't sure what
you were going to see for all you know
you might see something really
special and unique so there was always
kind of like this anticipation for the
end
the ends weren't used were usually not
satisfying like they weren't quite as
the game wasn't quite as big as you
thought it would be or it wasn't quite
as clever as you thought it would be
once it was over you know
well i kind of i mean i feel like that
was a limitation of the format because
it wasn't for lack of imagination
it's funny because when you look back at
some of the like atari games and stuff
like that particularly back in the
really old days when it was just like
[ __ ] pixelated nothing
and it's just funny how these whole
games like they had these whole
backstories like for like i'm thinking
of like the et game and like the movie
tie-in ones
and it's or the indiana jones one
to for one that actually sold
rather than the e.t one
but um but yeah but that's what i'm
saying it's like they had this whole
like back story about here's indy doing
this and i'm just like oh you mean these
little squares yeah moving across the
thing for to the other squares and it's
just it looks like nothing but it's just
like this whole you really really had to
use your imagination
i mean nothing looked like anything now
everything almost looks like an like a
movie well what was funny is you you
read into [ __ ] and your imagination
would get tied up with the game
and it was more mysterious
you thought it was more mysterious than
it really was like one of the games that
really
had me mystified and i wanted to be able
to finish it but i didn't have access to
it
for long enough was wizardry 2.
i imagined that that game was a lot more
sophisticated than it really was
remember do you know what you've ever
heard of wizardry 2. i've heard of it
but i don't really remember it was on
apple 2e and see i didn't have an apple
ii that was a home computer yeah and it
had
a window of a 3d
map of a dungeon that you went through
today you would laugh at it but back
then the idea of a 3d
and it was like in its day it was
[ __ ] way ahead of his time it was a
real good rpg
my shit's go it's yeah it's flashing
like red uh yellow red to yellow
it said it disconnected and then it said
it reconnected but i'm not sure if it
doesn't see it i see it right here it's
[ __ ] up over here on mine too yeah
i mean we'll see if it like it said it
reconnected but it's okay okay it's back
to it it's back to green now so
i don't know what happened
was a real good game for its time
um and it was better than anything on it
what the [ __ ] man yeah
everybody's online tonight i guess yeah
it was a good game for his time and it
was better than anything on any home
system
where we are barely missing this stream
is [ __ ] weak as [ __ ]
but
looking back on it you get modern copies
and it's almost kind of unplayable
compared to what's around today
and you see the system that they used in
the format and it's not
it's not as um
immersive as it was you know i mean i
can remember being a kid playing
wizardry on the [ __ ] school computer
in brazil because they had school
computers there
and it kind of had a creepy feel to it
but that was only back in those days you
know you can't
well like i said well because back in
the old days you had to use your
imagination so you almost had to immerse
yourself
otherwise you couldn't really enjoy it
that you that you didn't know the
limitations of the technology so you
were always kind of anticipating that
maybe something
real [ __ ] weird would happen or that
you know what i mean like
you weren't sure what the game could do
or what was going to happen you
know oracle said they turned dragon's
lair into a saturday morning cartoon too
as i recall yeah i think they did
actually i think i saw a couple episodes
of that the best thing about a dragon's
lair was the damn princess's boobs
though
well of course and you only saw her
boobs at the end of the game and they
teased the boobs at the beginning of the
game that's why they do that was like
the reward for like everybody that's the
only if you want 13 year old boys to
play to the end of your video game just
say that they're gonna see some boobs at
the end back in the 80s when you
couldn't just see boobs everywhere
that's why that's what it was all it was
like super special and some people were
like well
the animation was almost
disney style animation and she looked
like a sexy disney princess
and every time she'd laugh and giggle
[ __ ] she had a real low cut [ __ ]
see-through [ __ ] princess outfit and
the [ __ ] the boobs would [ __ ]
jiggle and fly around
so the dudes are like oh i gotta play
this game
she's jumping around save me and the
[ __ ] boobs are going boing
[Laughter]
they knew exactly what they were doing
just yeah just like all those movies in
the 80s where they're like hey the girls
with no bras it's like hey run away from
the killer yep speaker poops
the hades were unabashed about that they
understood very well the [ __ ] well
they knew what their who their audience
was
well they knew their own biology of a 14
15 year old boy
well [ __ ] man [ __ ] no adult men
[ __ ] okay you had
i would submit that there is very little
difference between an adult man and a
fourteen fifteen year old boy there's no
there's really nothing the difference is
that
the adult man now understands the game
the [ __ ]
the four the 15 year old boy believes it
he doesn't he doesn't understand the
illusion yet
that's the only difference yeah that's
the only difference yeah the grown man
knows it's dumb
okay he does it anyway but he knows
he just thinks it's funny you know what
i mean but the boy believes it he
believes the hook line of sinker
yeah yeah he's believing that he's
believing the fantasy
oh my goodness yeah
tony says you look beautiful jen thank
you love your hair thank you very much
yeah she's got the new boots on that i
bought her for uh christmas i mean
should i i was gonna like try it well
okay
yeah tom bought me these boots for
christmas they're black velvet little
goth boots they can't see on that side
sure on the other side
show them the buckles on the other side
i can't see
yeah
they're like velvety yeah black velvet
moves black velvet
please
anybody remember that song did that
[ __ ] have any more hits or not what was
her name
elena miles sandra shows up
oh i wanted to say oh sandra's here okay
i wanted to i wanted to give a shout out
to sandra because she sent me a paypal
donation earlier today well thank you
very much so thank you very much for new
year sandra you missed um my uh mexican
luchador
well you might have to put it back on
you should put it back on and then what
if somebody wanted the wanted the mozart
wig over or the judge wig i call it the
mozart wig
or the sally salieri
although sally aries wig was like kind
of more
was kind of brown
see there you go
[Laughter]
oh he's going to get the wig he's going
to do it he's going to do it he said he
wasn't going to do it but he is going to
do it oh my god that's awesome
um
straddling 78 said everyone kept saying
that uh samus uh from
metroid got naked at the end of the game
yeah it's i actually really liked that
because that was kind of one of the
first things where it's like you played
the whole game through and then they're
like
psych it's a woman
yeah
you thought it was a dude the whole time
yeah she took her helmet on my hair came
out yeah i remember that
and i remember everybody being like whoa
it was a girl the whole time
like it was like some big mind-blowing
thing we thought it was cool
i don't that's very very weird-looking
[Laughter]
batman last time i saw you i broke your
bones next time i see you i break your
soul
david june laughs and he says haha
that's ridiculous
yeah
honestly i think the mullet might have
worked better
you think no i don't think
yeah i know i know you don't
[Laughter]
all right i have to go to the bathroom
so you really need to what are you doing
i'm fixing this so talk entertainment
yeah i remember when we were playing
metroid um
grandfathers we were we were down in
steve's basement
and i'm trying to remember who it was
that was playing metroid
i think it might have been i think it
might have been jason
i think jason was playing it
and we got to the very end
and then they go through a little thing
and a little metroid sits up there samus
i think what the name is
and the helmet comes off and the hair
comes out and we just laugh
we're like oh it's a girl we didn't know
but you know
we thought that was cool
you know
because they they knew you weren't
expecting it you were thinking that it
was the whole time it was a
little man running around zapping all
the all the bad guys
so let's see what time it is
6 34. yeah you know
those little retro video games they were
you know they were good in the time in
the day
but uh you know some of the [ __ ] they
have today is
in recent history i would say just all
the the fallout you know i played a lot
of the fallout games
fall out
quickie flipped out when i sat down in
the chair because she's right back there
they fall out here yeah i just fall out
three and then i played
new vegas and then uh i got to fall out
i think four
and they came out like 76. i haven't
played that one
but i'm still not done with uh all the
add-ons to think fallout 4.
i'm doing that far harbor right now but
i did nuka world
honestly i really like the fallout games
like i i don't like i don't even care
about playing them but
they're just like fun to watch they're
kind of like relaxing yeah the music is
relaxing honestly i kind of like it when
you're just like walking around
in the wasteland and you're
decorating your
apartment
yeah
like putting in some carpets stuff
yeah it's like i don't know why that's
just like really relaxing well it's you
you can take your time you're like [ __ ]
it i'm just gonna build this and i'm
gonna do this that's what i mean i kind
of feel like i like that in video games
where it's just kind of this whole
entire world you can explore so it's
almost kind of like living an actual
other life rather than
you know there's a thing like the 80s
video games you kind of had to like they
were it was a video game you got in
there and you played and it was just
kind of like you had to do everything
like super fast and or you get killed or
whatever so i kind of like
this more sprawling
relaxing
kind of [ __ ] in in fallout 4 i got a
house
at home plate
that has arcade video games in it
constantly and you can build them
and they're stand up arcade games and
then you can play a video game inside
the video game
they got one of them it's like a missile
command copy another one it's kind of
like a wizardry copy or you know like a
dungeon dragons type copy and uh
one of them i think it's like a pitfall
copy
you know they had like six or seven
different games i don't remember them
all
but uh you can get the plans for them
and you can build them
if you have the
materials that kind of that's like super
cool to me that's a to me that's like
way more fun
than because i don't need any more
[ __ ] stress in my life yeah so i
don't need to be like playing video
games that are like stressing me out all
the time it's like look there's all
these zombies like coming right at your
face and you have to like shoot them
right now and it's just kind of like i
don't i don't need that kind of stress
in my life yeah so that's why i think
that's kind of why i like fallout yeah
there's monsters in it but
you don't have to engage with them you
can be like hey i'm just gonna hang out
in my bunker for
a few days and yeah just put some
like hang some pictures on the wall you
got to do stuff to progress but you
progress your own speed that's what i
mean that's i kind of like that it's
kind of and it's just like i said it's a
whole world that you can explore that's
like pretty neat
danny rolling ghostface says you
probably like the sims video games
honestly that's one thing that i've
always been meaning to get into it's
weird because
i mean tom plays a lot of video games
like i said he mostly plays kind of like
he plays a lot of fallout and he plays
um he used to play like the tomb raider
games like the old ones
and
i always like some of them look really
fun and i used to play a lot of video
games back in the old days like in the
nintendo and sega days like i used to
play [ __ ]
like i said castlevania i used to play
sonic the hedgehog i just play all that
kind of stuff
but
i don't know i just don't have enough
time and i kind of feel like i'm one of
those people that if i got super into
one game that it would kind of like eat
up all my
all my free time and i wouldn't really
have time to do anything else so i
haven't really got into it but
honestly i've seen so many games that
are so cool that
i don't know i kind of want to get back
into it honestly i really liked
the first
i can't believe it was like the first
walking dead game because i remember
like tom played that that was like a few
years back
and i remember really liking that like
the writing for it the um
characterization it was like really
really good and i think i bought him
the second one
maybe like a few years back for his
birthday or something but i remember
those being like cool because sometimes
i don't like i don't play them but i
usually just kind of like hang out and
like watch him play
it's just kind of that kind of thing i'm
too lazy to even get involved i'm just
kind of like you just play i'm just
gonna lay back here on the bed and eat
some snacks and like watch you um
yeah resident evil
yeah i've never played resident evil
um
people have told me like play silent
hill too which always seemed really
interesting to me i like like a lot of
the horror type games
but i just never have time to do them
you know
i just feel like i don't have
tommy actually looks a bit like popeye
[Laughter]
holy parish of doom says my wife loves
castlevania i haven't seen like i'm sure
because i think castlevania is still a
thing right
i mean i think they've still done it i
haven't played it since the really old
days since the old nes
days
and i used to really like it then but
i haven't seen it since then i remember
that being wicked hard because i
remember me and my brother used to play
it and my brother would get like so
[ __ ] frustrated because he couldn't
kill [ __ ] dracula at the end
because well the thing is you killed him
and then you were like woohoo i killed
him like it took forever and you died
like a million times and then you killed
him and you were all excited and then
like he just regenerated and you were
like [ __ ] me now what
i just remember it being really hard i
don't even remember if we ever beat it
did we what's that castlevania
which castlevania there's a million of
them the nintendo one the earl the early
one the nes one i don't know i wasn't
with you
i did it i beat it
i'm talking about like yeah i'm talking
about the old one me and my brother used
to play it yeah i beat it yeah long time
ago though that was the stand up arcade
version though it took a long time to
get through it
i remember it you could pick up
different weapons you could have the
damn
knives
you could throw
lances been a long time so another one i
i like
and i like the home version
there's a couple different versions of
it
um one version i bought for uh
xbox one
was
shinobi shinobi shinobi was a good game
you know it's a ninja game
yeah i remember you downloading that one
i need to get back on shinobi because i
never i haven't beaten the x the uh the
home version of it it gets harder and
harder the boss fights
first symphony says the newer tomb
raider games are amazing they're like
crazy 80s action movies
what was the last tomb raider that you
had i had them all up all the ones with
laura with the with the with the old
laura crawford the
boob laura croft
um the um the one where she goes down
underneath the water
and uh unlocks
uh nephelheim with all the damn norse
gods what was the name of that one
um because that was a few i mean we're
usually like a few years behind with
video games yeah i'll play the old games
i'll go back and play old games the new
ones with the new character
they're real expensive uh last time i
saw them yeah you should always like
wait a year or two because they always
want to charge you like 60 bucks 100 or
100 bucks when the first [ __ ] comes out
but if you wait a year or two they'll
like they're yeah they wanted 100 if
that's that's getting everything and all
the other you know like all the
different you know you want to get the
whole package
you know so you have the game and then
all the bonus stuff and then like the
bonus because there's bonus games and
expansion packs it's about
90 something bucks
for it
and if you just get the game itself it's
like 70 so you might as well just get
the you know what i mean
in those when you fork out the extra
[ __ ] 30 bucks and get that other
[ __ ] hundred dollars worth of [ __ ]
that they'll that they want to piecemeal
sell you to
you know
well honestly that's kind of one of the
things i know they're kind of expensive
when they first come out but if you
really want to play it i don't really
think it's um
it's a you know i don't think they're
ripping you off because that's like
hours and hours and hours of
entertainment because like i said it's
not just the main game but there's all
these kind of like offshoot sort of
games and it's like all these expansions
and stuff like that and you get all this
stuff to it it's like i said you could
play that for like [ __ ] weeks at a
time yeah so i'd be willing to pay 70 80
90 dollars for [ __ ] weeks of
entertainment sure i also like the uh
the tomb raider games from uh xbox or uh
the old xbox and xbox 360 you know like
legend that was a real good one i have
legend i can play that one over and over
again
um and there's another one that's a
little anniversary is the other one
that's similar to legend
i think there's three of them that are
like that
but i have all the old ones and then
the newer ones that were like from xbox
is 360. so i think that was [ __ ] what
was the name of those
they had a lot better [ __ ] graphics
more realistic look good
she's
better water graphics
you're running around [ __ ] riding
motorcycles out in central america and
trying to [ __ ]
um solve these puzzles and moving the
sundials and
going down underneath the ground
although you know they were just really
good games you could she could climb on
the walls different ways she's doing
like parkour almost and just hanging by
her fingers tips and jumping from one
little column to the next
well see i always liked more like puzzle
type games than like shooter type games
but the nice thing about tomb raider is
that it kind of combines both it was
both of those i mean it's mostly puzzle
stuff but then there's like shootout
types
running and jumping climbing trying to
figure out what goes where putting
things there and moving things around
figuring out how to fix things it's a
good kind of like all um you know just
all different kinds of games like in one
game which i think is kind of cool
which i guess fallout is kind of like
that too because it's kind of like
problem solving like every now like if
you're going across the wasteland and
there's like monsters and stuff and you
got to shoot them but
you know it's mostly just like problem
solving building
that kind of stuff and i kind of like
that
more expansive kind of game than just
like a shooter because to me shooters
get like just boring after a while
they're fun for because i used to play
doom too like when we first got a pc
back in the 90s
but
after a while it's just kind of like
okay
i'm shooting zombies i actually like all
of the old dooms better than the new
dooms i got do i think it's called doom
eternal one of the newer ones not the
brand new one but the one that came
after
and i've pretty much beat it but i can't
beat that last boss
i think i don't have enough upgrades yet
it's this damn skull spider thing
you think you got it beat and it just
keeps coming back for more and more
things come up out of the ground and
[ __ ] you got to jump on top of them
and it freezes the ground and
it gets frustrating
but um
when it comes to doom i did enjoy that
game but it's almost kind of like
too much is like too much almost it's
better if it's more simple i like the
old doom
like doom two
and then like [ __ ] the doom for from
um
n64 i got i got that doom but it's
[ __ ] upgraded for xbox xbox one so
the controls are better
that one's fun i got perfect dark that
came off of n64 for xbox one that's
that's a good game
i'd like to get the old um
uh double 07 golden eye but they haven't
released it they haven't remastered yeah
everybody's everybody talks about how
cool that guy was really cool
really good music it was real good
gameplay it was like one of the first
route first first person shooters it was
good the problem is is that n64
was a controller that only had one
joystick and it didn't quite work well
the new
dual joystick controllers man it works a
lot better [ __ ]
perfect dark which is the same game just
reskinned
more more futuristic looking because
they didn't have a license that same
company they just couldn't get the
double 07 license again so they took
that same engine and turned her into a
female high-tech spy it's also a good
game
but um yeah
they're supposed to supposedly
somebody's remastered it but they don't
have the license to release it
yeah because you know right
james bond stuff is expensive
yeah you gotta just leak it for free
yeah i mean you could get away with it
as long as you weren't charging people
money and you just can't people money i
mean unless they wanted to be like
buttholes
but you know
usually they're not going to come down
too hard on you if you release stuff
and you're not paying
you're not having people pay for it that
original golden eye
that's when i first met my first wife
and i was torn between
knocking her down and playing that game
that's how [ __ ] good that game was
i'm sure she was thrilled about that
she's like yeah so i don't know if i had
time i have to compete with a video game
really
yeah
that's how good that game was
is that even a guy in his 20s were
having a hard time choosing
this is why ladies like are
like fine dudes tiresome
you come back to bed
[Laughter]
you gotta understand something man this
is the james bond game this is way more
this is way bigger than all of us i'm in
russia right now
out in the snow trying to fight these
dudes man
and then the next thing you know i'm on
i'm on the arecibo telescope fighting
these dudes she's gonna go find a sancho
[Laughter]
who's sancho i don't know
will he bring me some will he bring me
some burritos that's the bigger question
[Laughter]
david june says castlevania 2 or 3 was
impossible
i used a game shark and could never beat
dracula okay so i don't feel so bad then
i don't even remember
like i said we had the
nes castlevania i don't even remember if
we ever beat it we got to dracula made
it multiple times
but
it just like it took forever it took
forever and then like you kept dying and
then like you thought you killed we're
like oh my god we [ __ ] killed him and
then like he just like popped back up
like
i'm back [ __ ] i'm dracula and we were
like [ __ ] me what now what
and then you had to like fight him again
and then you died because obviously you
know by then all your hit points were
gone yeah they're talking about the
licensing problems with gold knight
it's a shame man but
i jenny was will witness this
i came this close to buying an n64 just
to play goldeneye yeah
i also wanted to play rogue squadron
though the original old rogue squadron
was really good but i hated that single
joystick controller man that [ __ ] sucked
you just couldn't get strafing right
although it wasn't so bad on on on rogue
squadron
and you had to had that little expansion
chip for it which made it a little bit
better i think
but those two games were pretty good so
was quake
and the the uh
that doom game that they had was pretty
good
n64 was a and i really liked the zelda
uh ocarina of time
yeah
it was fun
all the zelda games were yeah i don't
know if it would hold up i haven't
played it forever
but um
it'd be nice maybe to get something like
that just walk down memory lane you know
what i mean it'll it'll it'll attach to
a modern television you can play it
well that's what i mean see that's
what's cool about nowadays is that you
have access to all
all of the entertainment
from now backwards whether it's movies
video games music anything you can
access anything you want yeah
you know back then we didn't have that
option it's just kind of like well you
had what was there
now you can like well i can play new
[ __ ] or i can play old [ __ ] or i could
do like i said it's the same with music
or movies or anything you can watch you
can watch nothing but old movies your
whole entire life if you wanted to even
even if you're 20 years old which that's
like pretty awesome yeah you know
everything's available
which oh i saw something i saw something
that i wanted to say something about it
uh danny rowland ghostface says the
golden eye remake for the wii is really
good it has online gameplay just saying
yeah i don't know
i don't know if that's the same game
though
the thing that made goldeneye for n64 so
good was the smoothness of the gameplay
and how good that game was
and
you can't change the game too much part
of this part of the
part of the uh the charm of it was some
of its little foibles
the thing that i didn't like about it
was that was the it was the controls the
control system the joystick wasn't any
good but that wasn't the game that was
the system
somebody was saying that they were going
to
remaster it to make it look a little bit
better but the same game and then adjust
it to an an xbox style controller
and that's really all you need you don't
need
you don't need a new game you need that
same game just slightly
tweaked for free modern modern that's
all you need right
and honestly there's an odd there's a
built-in audience for it out there
because i felt like not just you and
i've seen like a lot of younger people
that talk about video games talking
about goldeneye and how i mean that's
kind of one of the games that everybody
talks about from that era
it started first-person shooters really
yeah it was the first real good
first-person shooter
i couldn't believe it
when i saw it i was like god damn i just
could not believe that game
i couldn't believe that it was a home
system
doing that
like oh my god what a time to be alive
[Laughter]
little did we know what would happen
later on it's been kind of cool though
i'm really glad it's it sucks being old
but
i really like having
um
i guess like straddled both worlds
like because we grew up in a time before
the internet before home computers
really
i mean the internet
home computers didn't really become a
thing until i was
all like pretty much in high school
so it was kind of cool like seeing
you know just just being on straddling
that line like seeing what the world was
like before that and then just seeing
what happened like after that
and being like cognizant of all the
changes that were happening
so people are saying that what will
happen people are saying that [ __ ]
that it won't happen yeah i don't think
it will happen
not officially
if it ever happens it'll be something
bootleg
yeah you just have to like
whoever does it just has to release it
for you evidently there's no money
evidently there is one ready to go
that um
somebody's done it
but it was somebody that was associated
with that company
i don't remember what company it was
somebody just mentioned it rare i think
it might have been the company was the
name of the studio that did it
somebody involved with that team touched
it up and then it would run great on a
xbox 360 or
or excuse me xbox one or a new
playstation it would work on a pc
it's just that the licensing they can't
release it they just need to leak it
just give it out for free
you know
make money off of merchandising
licensing's a [ __ ] man
it really is i was just reading an
article earlier maybe they think they'll
eventually get the licensing for it i
mean you know
i was reading an article earlier about
how apparently somebody somewhere
wants to make a 13th
friday the 13th movie
because i mean that's really got to
stick in people's craw that they made 12
of them and there should be a 13th one
but the problem being
that jason the character
um
depending on what iteration of jason
you're talking about is owned by two
different people
like steve miner and all them that did
like the first couple movies
they kind of owned the rights to jason
as a kid and the whole crystal lake
concept and like the mom and all that
um but then like the later movies that
actually had like the hockey mask and
everything that's owned by a different
that's like a different thing so if you
want to make any kind of like expansive
friday the 13th movie for example you
have to really negotiate all of these
different like
rights but honestly i would not want to
be like a [ __ ]
entertainment lawyer or a copyright
lawyer no [ __ ] way
yeah all of the [ __ ] complications
that you have to go through
it's like who how many people do you
have to pay to like just make this one
[ __ ] movie or video game or whatever
well jenny if you want to uh get
something to eat
and you want to get there early which i
think we should we probably ought to
kind of close the stream down
you think yeah yeah it's almost seven
it's almost seven and we had to leave it
probably about an hour and then risk
should we have to do so yeah because i
i wouldn't even mind leaving it a little
early i wouldn't mind leaving in a half
hour actually
okay but we need well we need to get
some sandwiches that's what i'm saying
we need to get some hams we're gonna get
some sandwiches yeah and then we'll go
and then we'll you need to like relax a
little bit yeah and then yeah we'll head
out i'll handle it
you sure yeah i'll make some sandwiches
all right that sounds good actually
so you know all right so
okay hopefully you guys had a good time
hanging out with us this new year's eve
uh we're gonna go get something to eat
and then we're gonna
go drive down to downtown sanford we're
gonna go to mannequins and see how that
goes
new year's fetish ball hopefully it's
not a big [ __ ] [ __ ] down there
but we'll see it's gonna be
i mean i'm sure but that's that's why we
want to go down there early
hopefully hopefully i don't have to stop
for gas i think
yeah i can't say i put a shot on the gas
in there earlier
but uh but yeah so we will be back on
sunday afternoon
talking about
whatever movie we're gonna talk about
so everybody have a good new year's eve
happy new years happy 2022.
hopefully this year is better than the
last couple of been because [ __ ] man
last couple years have been kind of a
[ __ ] show but you know
just i'm staying optimistic so everybody
else stay optimistic also we will see
you guys on sunday afternoon thank you
everybody for dropping by thanks for
super chats and we will see you guys on
sunday
bye